frédéric tellier au milieu des élèves le
temps d'une photo et d'un échange et
c'est dans son collège raymond poincaré
de versailles qui partage son amour du
septième art y a pas forcément besoin de
faire une école de faire du cinéma
personnellement j'ai même toujours
refusé d'aller faire des master classes
dans les écoles de cinéma pour cette
raison là je pense que la meilleure
école c'est celle du tas je suis revenu
avec l'idée alors faire passer que le
mois pour le moment toute ma vie aura
été habité par l'idée de la culture et
de partager la culture
que ce soit du divertissement ou de la
culture des films plus grave au plus
léger
max a embelli la vie on vit mieux saint
john perse disait j'écris pour mieux
vivre moi je fais du cinéma pour mieux
vivre
le réalisateur de la fresque à 1 et les
hommes de l'ombre participe à la
septième édition d'un artiste à l'école
une édition parrainée cette année par
julie gayet l'idée c'est de montrer aux
élèves qui sont actuellement dans le
collège que certains des anciens élèves
ont eu un parcours remarquable et que
donc voilà ils peuvent espérer s'appuyer
sur l'expérience qu'ils ont déjà dans le
collège
et voilà envisager de vidéos tout
simplement un collège qui a développé
des vocations artistiques
raymond poincaré a vu grandir
l'intouchable eric toledano et l'auteur
chanteur guèye faye